Freak bitches,
like my friend Remy,
Remy Warren was in New Zealand and a
used one of those and like wrote in the
log,
you know,
where he was from when he was there.
And I guess it also,
it helps identify if people are missing.
Exactly,
yeah.
I think it's a safety precaution.
So if you can kind of track down where
it was the last person seen,
you know,
or wherever they last seen.
So if they were,
if they logged into a shelter and then,
you know,
they can't find them,
they can say okay,
on this date we know that they were here
so you can give a given radius and know
that if they are missing their within at
least within a certain,
you know,
20 miles in distance walking distance of
their.
But yeah.
And I think those things actually turned
into like a just fun.
You know,
some people just go write full on poems
in there,
some,
you know,
confess like life stories and they're
like,
Oh God,
yeah.
The trail log books are entertaining the
doubt.
Wow.
Here,
warning,
what does it say?
Harassing Baron Camp Night of 5:11 swipe
clause in two tents.
Stepped on my tent.
Tila collapsed on me.
Please be careful he didn't even try to
get the food hanging low on a branch
here.
Oh,
look at her name.
Flower.
Passion flower with a sad face and
there's another one.
Bear rip.
This is a different.
This is a different person's
handwriting.
Bear ripped the bag hanging on my pack,
which was hanging on my hammock.
I was Muslim.
Say Bullshit.
Bouncing,
bouncing up and down.
He stole my toilet paper.
Exclamation point.
What does that say?
Subway.
That's his name.
Eat fresh.
Yeah.
Ps,
the Pivi is great.
What's a pivot?
Are Pretty.
It's the a privilege.
It's just like an outhouse.
Oh,
okay.
Compost.
Toilet.
How about this one?
Dat Shit.
Cray all balls.
Ghetto savior.
Baltimore.
What?
All balls?
Ghetto savior.
Baltimore.
Okay.
Well you're dealing with like fringe
people,
right?
I mean these are people that are just
not fitting into the corporate module.
I don't what what you're talking about
with the New York Times and I don't
really.
I'm not going to step out and take a
view on it,
but what,
what I believe you're saying with the
times is that they were pro Clinton and
anti trump.
That's different from having a position
on climate change.
Well,
it's not.
no,
because they have a position on just
just take the Lens as climate change.
You have one candidate who is denying
the reality of climate change.
Where?
Who's,
who's just claiming that the Chinese
trump?
Well,
no,
because it won't because when trump says
climate change is a Chinese hoax,
you have to call him.
Here we go.
He said it's a Chinese hoax.
He should go to China and see those
people that are walking around with gas
masks on because they can't breathe in
Beijing.
Okay.
But that's,
I mean that's,
that's the pollution,
right?
Which I think is actually much stronger
because that's just.
You can't go to Beijing and say this is
how we want the air to be.
Right.
But I think something like 20,
I think something like 25 percent of the
air pollution in California on some days
is coming from China.
Maybe there's some amazing pr.
I could have that slightly wrong.
Jamie can check that out,
but please do.
There's some,
there's some extraordinary amount of
Arab air pollution that we get from
China.
That's insane.
I did not know that.
It makes its way across the ocean.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
it does.
There's no wall build that wall,
but.
No,
but at a certain point,
I mean there's some,
there's some level of dishonesty and
misinformation that's so egregious that
if you're a journalist coming at all
committed to being an unbiased or
disinterested broker of information and
a conversation,
if you set up a conversation between,
you know,
the Sean Spicer's of the world or the
Kellyanne Conway's who were,
have their alternative facts and someone
who's honestly talking about whatever it
is,
climate change,
um,
it's very,
you know,
you can't split that up
baby,
but I don't think you have to create
mock unnecessary debates around climate
change.
What I do think is that,
uh,
with the trump administration,
that it is imperative for journal that
journalists a call out when things are
said that aren't true,
but I don't think it's constructive for
mainstream journalistic organizations to
have an openly hostile anti-trump
attitude or pro somebody else attitude
because then you lead that just leads to
further polarization,
but when you exactly what we don't need,
but you call them out on all the times
that he said things that were just
absolutely not true.
That's like your anti trump.
Yes,
it can.
There's no question.
And uh,
and I think that's,
uh,
an issue we're dealing with and I,
but I think this is a time of real soul
searching in my industry because I,
I firmly believe there is a very
powerful place in a functioning
democracy for a press,
for,
for media that people generally view as
fair.
I don't know how they do it,
but they figured out how to splice
things and change things and selectively
breed certain plants and they came up
with different strains.
That's why corn looks the way it looks.
Old school corn was like the size of a
Hobos Dick,
and it was so naughty and fucked up
look,
and it was like four inches long.
So it's a little tiny thing.
It tastes the same.
No,
I mean it's uh,
hobos.
Dick.
No.
Hobos dicks are weird,
man.
They're so variable.
You never know what you get.
And it could be a recent Hobo and be
like,
that guy who punched you.
Just old school snot blowing.
Veteran Dick.
Tastes like battery acid.
Those addict.
That's through the Pacific southwest
for guys just doing north northwell.
Danny comes in your mouth.
What do you think that to say that like,
oh,
guide drinks.
Orange juice has come taste better.
Have you heard that?
Yeah.
Whenever I heard that,
I was like,
how many dicks do you have to suck for
you figure that out.
You can get away from me.
Do you hold this fucking scientists?
He's sucking Dick with a lab coat on.
Taking notes,
asparagus.
Not recommended.
Switching it around in your mouth.
Like you're a wine connoisseur,
right?
If a guy eats pineapples,
if a guy eats pineapples,
is cum tastes better.
Right?
But conversely,
if you're just doing nothing but smoking
meth,
your loads have to taste like hot death.
Yeah.
And it does.
And it's fucking lumpy.
Pesticide loads.
Tastes like roundup.
It's not good when you have to kill it.
It's not much either.
It's like a fucking Hershey's kiss.
No
mother fucker
didn't.
She's immediately tripping on meth.
She's out of her mind.
By the time they came back then they
were different enough from coyotes that
they not only couldn't interbreed with
them anymore,
but they sort of are mortal enemies of
one another.
I mean,
when we reintroduced wolves to
yellowstone in 1995,
coyotes had had 75 years and yellowstone
without any wolves.
I mean.
And that served as a wonderful
laboratory to study them too because it
gave us a sense of what happens with
coyotes when nobody is harassing them
when people aren't harassing him,
which of course we didn't.
And Yellowstone Park and when wolves
aren't harassing them either.
And what we realize is that they create
these really stable territory's.
They create very stable packs and their
population rises to a particular point.
The carrying capacity of the landscape
based on what they eat,
which is mostly rodents and rabbits and
things and some fruit and berries,
but it doesn't,
they don't,
their populations sort of levels off and
stays at a carrying capacity.
And so we got to watch that happen in
yellowstone for like 75 years and it's
become sort of the,
the example of what would happen if we
just left them alone.
I mean,
some people think,
well,
if we don't try to control them,
how they're gonna,
you know,
they're just going to be millions upon
millions of them running everywhere,
but that's actually,
they only do that when you try to
persecute them and they go into this
colonization mode and generate more and
more and more pups and have more and
more pups survive.
So yellowstone in that period from 19,
25 to 1995 was this sort of model of
what happens when you just leave them
the hell alone and they just kind of
rise to a particular population level
and are really stable at that level.
And uh,
and don't really go beyond it.